اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه المفصله من العربيه والتي
نبداها بالعناوين
قائد الجيش السوداني يقول انه ملتزم
بالعمليه السياسيه التي تقود الى قيام
سلطه مدنيه
رغم الهدنه المعلنه تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
المنطقه الصناعيه بالخرطوم جراء
الاشتباكات
تعد هذه الرحله وهذه السفينه هي الاكبر
منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء كعددا وحجم حتى
هذه اللحظه السفينه السعوديه امانه تنفذ
اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان واجمالي يصل
لنحو
4900 شخص
الرئيس التركي يظهر للمره الاولى شخصيا
على محطات تركيه بعد ايام من تعرضه لوعكه
صحيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قال مسؤول في الجيش
السوداني في تصريحات للعربيه ان التقارير
التي تتحدث عن نقل الجيش المعركه لدارفور
مضلله واتهم قوات الدعم السريع بدرفور
بمهاجمه قوات الجيش واثاره الفتنه بين
القبائل من جهاته قال رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح برهان الجيش لن يكون
رافعه لاي كيان او حزب او جماعه لانقضاض
على السلطه واكد البرهان ان الجيش
السوداني ملتزم بالعمليه السياسيه التي
تقود لقيام سلطه مدنيه على حد وصفه
وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه في السودان
تتواصل اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في عده نقاط خاصه العاصمه الخرطوم
رغم موافقه الطرفين على هدنه خامسه لوقف
اطلاق النار كما تشهد سماء الخرطوم تحريقا
كثيفه لطائرات حربيه في وقت تسمع اصوات
داوي المدفعيه ومضادات الطيران اما في
مدينه ام درمان فقد ادى سقوط قذيفه على
احد المنازل الى مقتل شخص
قال الجيش السوداني في بيان رسمي انما حصل
كان محاوله فاشله للاستيلاء على الحكم
بقوه المتمردين واكدا ان محاوله المتمردين
المتمردين واعوانهم من عملاء الداخل
والخارج في التسويق لمشروعهم القائم على
تزييف الحقائق قد فشلت واشار البيان الى
ان المعركه وحلت الشعب وقواته المسلحه
وزادت من حرص ابناء الوطن على اهميه بقاء
قوته المسلحه كما اكد البيان على العمل
على تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لكل اجهزه
الدوله لاستئناف عملها وعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها باسرع وقت ممكن
بدورها اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بخلق الهدنه الانسانيه المتفق
عليها عبر مهاجمه مراكزها وعدد من الاحياء
السكنيه في الخرطوم بواسطه الطيران
والبيدفعيه هذا وجددت قوات الدعم السريع
في بيان الله التزامها الكامل بالهدنه
الانسانيه المعلنه لفتح ممرات امنه
للمواطنين لقضاء احتياجاتهم ولتسهيل
عمليات الاجلاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ظهرت لقطات فيديو ترحيب مواطنين سودانيين
بنزول قوات شرطه الاحتياط المركزي وسط
منطقه السوق المركزي في العاصمه الخرطوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الرباعي الطيران
افادت نقابه اطباء السودان بارتفاع ضحايا
الاشتباكات في البلاد الى 411 قتيلا من
المدنيين واصابه 2022 اخرين واوضحت
النقابه في بيان ان الاقتتال الاخير في
مدينه الجنينه اوقع تسعا 89 قتيلا مشيره
بل 89 قتيلا مشيره الى انه لا يوجد حصر
دقيق لعدد الاصابات واضافت النقابه ان
جميع المستشفيات في المدينه خارج الخدمه
ومن الخطوط مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك السالم
والجديد الاوضاع لديك في الخرطوم
طيب يبدو ان الزميل سالم لا يسمعني سنعود
اليك مره اخرى في سياق هذه النشره الى
مشاهدينا اظهرت صور التقطت اليوم انتشار
قوات الشرطه السودانيه في جميع مناطق
الخرطوم نتابع
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بادخال اسلحه وجنود لمستشفى
الخرطوم وبتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس
لسكنات عسكريه وجاء في البيان ان
المتمردين مستمرون بقصف الخرطوم اودرمان
لاجبار السكان على الاخلاء الافتن الى ان
القصف العشوائيه مستمر في محيط قياده بحر
والقياده العامه والدفاع الجوي واضاف
الجيش انه نفذ عمليات اجلاء عبر مطاري
وادي سيدنا اوفر سودان لرعايه بعض الدول
نعود مره اخرى الى براسينا في الخرطوم
سالم الهاشمي اليك سالم واخر ما لديك
بمعلومات وتفاصيل حول الوضع في الخرطوم
مرحبا احمد وبكل الساده المشاهدين الخرطوم
تشهد هدوءا نسبيا او ازدادت وتيره هذا
الهدوء كل او تزداد ساعه بعد الاخرى هذه
الوتيره كذلك وتيره حركه المواطنين تزداد
كذلك في شوارع الخرطوم تنساب الحركه الى
حد كبير وفي مناطق متفرقه كذلك يخرج
المواطنون لقضاء حاجياتهم في مناطق متفرقه
وبعيده عن مناطق الاشتباكات مناطق
الاشتباكات نفسها شهدت هدوءا كذلك اليوم
وهذا هو الغريب منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات
حتى الان لا توجد لا يوجد يوم يعني وجد
فيه المواطنون هدوءا مثل هذا اليوم في
انحاء متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم حقيقه
هدوء اتمنى ان يستمر وان يكون شيئا يبنى
عليه بعد ذلك بالنسبه لحركه المواطنين
باتت شبه طبيعيه الان في العديد من مناطق
الخرطوم عاده الحياه ايضا الى مناطق بعيده
جدا مناطق الاشتباكات بدات تنساب المواد
الغذائيه ايضا شاهدنا بعض الاسواق بدات
تباشر اعمالها وان كان قليل لكنها بدات
بالفعل بعد ان كانت مغلقه تماما كذلك
محطات الوقود هناك محطات كانت مغلقه تماما
بدات في العمل ايضا رغم ان هذه الامور
محدوده الا انها تبشر بانه يمكن ان تمتد
هذه البشريات لتكون عامه في الايام
القادمه اخر التطورات بالنسبه للبيانات
بيان الجيش السوداني الذي صدر الذي اكد
فيه سعيه لحسم التمرد واكد فيه كذلك ان
المتمردين اكتسحوا المستشفيات
وان هناك مخططا كذلك دوليا او هناك ايضا
ايدي محليه عبثت بهذا الامر لسيطره هذه
الميليشيا على السلطه بالقوه بالاضافه الى
تفاصيل الاخرى التي وردت في هذا البيان
بيان الجيش يؤكد انه
سيجعل الحياه تعود الى طبيعتها وهو عدا
الموا بان ستعود الحياه كما كانت وبدا
بالفعل جزئيا هذا الامر ينساب بشكل طبيعي
لا احد كبير في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه
الخرطوم بالنسبه للوضع الانساني ما زال
يحتاج لمزيد هناك تحسن نسبي ايضا في بعض
المستشفيات بدات مستشفيات في العمل هذا
اليوم
مراكز ايضا صحيه بدات في العمل هذا اليوم
نذكر منها مثلا وحده غسيل الكلى في مستشفى
بدات وقد اعلنت قبل ساعات من الان انها
ستبدا في العمل مباشره ربما هذه امور
مبشرات جاءت بها هذه الهدنه الذي التي هي
الان على الارض الى حد كبير تم الالتزام
بها طيب من خلال الضمه تبعناهم الصور سالم
هناك ايضا انتشار لقوات الاحتياط المركز
التابع لقوات الشرطه السودانيه ما دلالات
نشر هذه القوات في هذا التوقيت وكيف ايضا
كان صدى ذلك لدى المواطنين
المواطنين فرحين جدا بانتشار قوات الشرطه
لان هذه المطالب ظلت منذ ايام يتم تداولها
بشكل واسع وكبير بالمطالبه بانتشار قوات
الشرطه وتامينها للممتلكات والمنشات
وتامين المواطنين كذلك ربما هذا الانتشار
يجب ان يكون اكثر هذا ما يطالب به
المواطنون وان يكون اكثر ايضا ربما تشهد
الساعات القادمه او يوم غد انتشار كثيف
لهذه القوات يكون بذلك فعلا يتحقق ما
يريده المواطن السوداني من تحقيق الامن
وانسياب المواد الغذائيه وانسياب المواد
البتروليه وان يعيش حياه طبيعيه بالفعل
لان قوات الشرطه هي منوط بها حمايه
المواطنين وتامين الممتلكات والمنشات هذا
الانتشار سيجد بكل تاكيد فرحا من كل
المواطنين خاصه بعد ايام الرعبه التي
عاشتها الخرطوم طيب ان نشاهد ايضا في هذه
الصور سالم ارتفاع او تصاعد لاعمه الدخان
في منطقه ما في الخرطوم الى ما يعد ذلك هل
هي نتيجه اشتباكات او هي حرائق لاشتباكات
قديمه ما الذي يحدث
نعم هو حدثت اليوم اشتباكات لكنها ليست
الاعنف كما ذكرت لك ربما تكون محدوده
للغايه هذه الاشتباكات اليوم في المنطقه
الصناعيه وفي محيط كافوري في مدينه بحري
وربما نتجت منها هذه الحرائق يضاف اليها
حريق الامس الذي كان ضخما كذلك في منطقه
الصناعات في بحر ايضا هذه المنطقه ربما
تشهد بشكل كبير وكثيف كذلك تشهد دائما
اشتباكات في تلك المنطقه بحكم ان هنالك
معسكر بقوات الدعم السريع يستهدفه الجيش
السوداني وان قوات الدعم السريع تتمركز في
تلك المنطقه
ووصف الجيش السوداني بانها تتمترس في هذه
المناطق وانها تلجا كذلك للمواطنين
لاستخدامهم كدروع البشريه في اكثر من مره
ذكر الجيش السوداني هذا الامر ربما هذا هو
السبب الذي يجعل هذه المنطقه ربما تشهد
نوع من انواع الاشتباكات او نوع من ربما
دعنا نقول هذا الذي يحدث
كذلك ايضا من هذه من الامور المهمه التي
شكى منها المواطنين في المنطقه الصناعيه
تحديدا انهم شاهدوا الكثير من عمليات
النهب والسرقه التي تتم لتلك المنطقه لعدم
وجود الشرطه في تلك المنطقه عدم انتشار
هذه القوات في هذه المنطقه وهذا الامر
يجعل مساله الخوف والهلع عند المواطنين في
محيط المنطقه الصناعيه ما زالت موجوده
ربما مساله الامن هذه تحتاج الى خطه واضحه
من الشرطه ببسط الامن ولو تدريجيا على
مناطق العاصمه الخرطوم نعم اذا ساكتفي
بهذا القدر ونكون معك في متابعه دائمه
لتفاصيل ما يحدث في خرطوم هذا اليوم شكرا
لكم مراسله العربيه سالم الهاشمي
حافه القوه المدنيه المواقعه لاتفاق
الاطاري في السودان الطرفين للالتزام
التام بوقف النار وشددت على ضروره التقيد
بتلك الهدنه التي وافق عليها قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السرعي
محمد حمدانو كما اشارته الى انها تشد على
ايدي قاده الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاطوا بايجابيه مع المبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه اما فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع في
الجنينه باقليم دارفور فاعتبرت ان
المواجهات القبليه الحاصله نتيجه مباشره
بلديه مباشره للقتال الذي اشتعل منذ 15 من
ابريل جاري بين القوتين العسكريتين
الكبيرتين في البلاد
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا الكاتب الصحفي محمد شمس الدين
اهلا بك سيد محمد دعنا للجزئيه الاخيره في
الخبر الذي قراته قبل قليل عن احتماليه
تمدد هذا الاشتباكات الى مناطق اخرى في
دارفور نتحدث عن الخرطوم رغم ان هناك مصدر
عسكريا نفى سعي الجيش لتوسيع دائره
الاشتباكات مع قوات الدعم السريع هل
دارفور هي بيئه خصيبه ومتاحه
لاندلاع هذه الاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
تحياتي لك اخي احمد واستاذ المشاهدين الى
مكان يعني تماما هي ربما البيئه الاكثر
خصوبه يعني مواصله او تواصل هذه العمليات
والاشتباكات وهي مندلعه اصلا قبل تفجر
الامور في العاصمه في الخرطوم
يعني تابعنا في الاخبار هذه
التفاصيل التي تتعلق ببعض المواقع في
دارفور والتي فيها نزاع مستمر اصلا منذ
اشهر تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات بين الفين
والاخرى قبل اسبوع تقريبا منطقه فور
برانجا كانت من احدى اسخن المواقع
العسكريه بين
مجموعات يعني في الفتره الماضيه كانت تسمى
اشتباكات قبليه طبعا هذه الاشتباكات
القبليه معروف انتماءات هذه المجموعات
المتنقله
لقوات الدعم السريع بصفه او باخرى كما
تقول التقارير الوارده من اقليم جارفور
سواء عبر المنظمات الحقوقيه او بعض شهود
العيان هذا
يعني امر بديهي بطبيعه الحال اذ ان
الحاضنه الاولى لهذه القوات اصلا هي منطقه
اقليم دارفور
هذه الاحصائيات التي ايضا ترد من من غرب
البلاد ليست بالاحصائيات النهائيه فيما
يتعلق باعداد الضحايا من الصعب جدا
التواجد اي من الجهات او المنظمات او
الوسائل الاعلام او الصحفيين في تلك
المناطق على الارض لتثبيت او تاكيد معلومه
فيما يتعلق به الاحصائيات او شكل
الاشتباكات حتى حتى هذه اللحظه هناك يعني
محاوله من الزملاء الصحفيين لتغطيه
يعني يرد من معلومات عبر المصادر الموثوقه
من مختلف مناطق دارفور
والوضع هناك لا يختلف كثيرا عن الخرطوم
فيما يتعلق بتوفير الحمايه الصحفيين او
غيرهم من الطواقم الطبيه او
الطواقم العامله في مجالات مختلفه
الشرطه غائبه تماما حتى هذه اللحظه وربما
القطاع الوحيد الذي
شوهد بالامس في يعني قوات او في شكل
التشكيلات جديده مشت ركه مع قوات الجيش هو
قطاع الاحتياطي المركزي في الخرطوم في بعض
المواقع يعني استعانت بهم قوات الجيش في
مواجهات جرت في حي بري بحسب افادات من
شهود عيان من تلك الاحياء طيب استاذ محمد
هذا ما يتعلق بجانب الامني والعسكري لو
انتقلنا الى الجانب السياسي هل في تقديرك
هناك حاجه لرسم خارطه طريق جديده في
السودان بعيدا عن الاتفاق الاطار والذي
ادى لاندلاع هذه المواجهات بين الطرفين
المتناحين
نعم هذا ما رصدناه ايضا من تحركات عدد
كبير من الكتل السياسيه
والشخصيات الوطنيه التي انخرطت في
تشكيل الجبهه مدنيه جديده لوقف القتال حتى
انها وزعت بيانا التاسيسيا تنسيقيا لهذه
الجبهه وبدات في حشد الجهود يعني انجاح
هذه المحاوله هذه المره لاعاده ترتيب
المشهد السياسي في البلاد البناء على ما
سبق يقول يعني هؤلاء القاده السياسيون
والشخصيات العامه بانه غير مجدي وبطبيعه
الحال لا يمكن البناء على ما تجرا يعني
سببا في يعني تفجر هذا المشهد بهذه
الطريقه وبهذه الصوره يلاحظ ايضا ان
القاده السياسيين الذين كانوا جزءا او
شكلوا المشهد السياسي في الفتره الماضيه
لاسيما النتيجه النهائيه له وهي الاتفاق
الايطالي يعني كانوا يصرون او لازالوا
يسرون بالمناسبه
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه نحن الان يعني على
مشاعر في الاسبوع الثالث كل المبادرات
التي انطلقت قبل اندلاع هذه الازمه وحتى
الان اتحدث عن مبادرات الداخليه وحتى
الخارجيه لم تنجح المبادره الوحيده التي
الوساطه الوحيده التي تجد صدى حتى هذه
اللحظه هي البساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
والتي يعني تشكل شكلا او قدرا من الضغط
المباشر على الطرفي القتال الان للانخراط
او العوده الى منصه التفاوض جديده ما بين
الطرفين لايقاف الحرب وايقاف نزيف الدماء
هذه هي الطريقه الوحيده بينما الجهود
المدنيه الاخرى السياسيه او الشخصيات
المستقله لم تجد اذان صغيره عند هذه او
عند الطرفي القتال حتى هذه اللحظه وهذا
يعني امر مؤسف يعني الدعوات ليست فقط من
القوى السياسيه بل من كل مواطني البلاد
نتحدث الى مختلف قطاعات الشعب السوداني
بينما نتحرك ونستمع منهم الى هذه النداءات
وهذه الرسائل باستمرار يعني يرسلون رسائل
الى انه لا طائل من هذه الحرب الخاسر فقط
هو الشعب السوداني
والاعداد الضحايا خير شاهد على هذا الامر
بكل اسف شديد الاعداد ليست نهائيه كما
يقول كل الذين يعني يقومون بعمليات احصاء
يعني اعداد القتلى والجرحى الاعداد يعني
مؤلمه بمعنى الكلمه
ايضا شكرا لك بهذا القدر من الخرطوم كنت
معنا الكاتب الصحفي محمد شمس الدين تحياتي
مشاهدينا وفي تصريح للعربيه قال يوسف عزه
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان ان قواته سيطرت على 90% من
ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع الصمود في
المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت
على الدعم السريع وان وقف اطلاق النار
مرتبط بتنفيذ الجيش لذلك واكد عزت في
لقائه مع العربي ان البرهان لا يدير
المعركه ولا يستطيع وقف النار
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست من الاشياء انها ليست
قوات منظمه تتبع خطط عسكريه
مرتبه لدينا وساطه من
امريكا ومدعومه من السعوديه لدينا وساطه
من العقاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره صديقه
ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن لسنا
دعاه حرب ولا نريد استمرار الحرب ولا نريد
معاناه شعبنا
اي هنالك حل ياسس لسلام دائم
ابدا قائد قوات الدعم السريع في مقابله مع
قناه بي بي سي استعداده لاجراء مفاوضات مع
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان بشرط وقف
اطلاق النار وقال اذاعه البريطانيه انه
طالب بالهدنه منذ اليوم الاول الحرب وان
قواته بدات بفتح ممرات انسانيه داخله
مناطق سيطرتها
مشاهدينا معي في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني محمود العوته اهلا بك سيد محمود
معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه دعنا نبدا
بتصريحاتيه التي عبر فيها عن استعداده
طبعا للجلوس على طائره المفاوضات مع قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان في اي سياق
قراءه هذه التصريحات والتي تاتي بعد 15
يوما من المواجهه العنيفه بين الطرفين
وطبعا الان بيشرح في الانباء او في الافق
في بعض الانباء الساره يمكن طلعت قبل
قليلا قبل ما ادخل الاستديو على لسان اللي
هو مندوب الامم المتحده في الخرطوم
فوركربيرس بانه تم تسميه الممثلان
للمفاوضات للجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
على اعتقد اجهزه سوف يمثل اللواء ركن ابو
بكر الفقيري
والدعم السريع العميد يوسف عثمان
ويتوقع ان تكون ان تعقد هذه الاقتراح طبعا
تعقد المفاوضات اما في جباء او في جده في
المدينه السعوديه انا اعلى يمكن على ضوء
هذا التسريحه اعتقد طلعت هذه
التسريبات وطلعت هذه الانباء ونعتقد هذه
اعتقد خطوه متقدمه
مدام تم تسميه
المرشحان
للمفاوضات بين الجانبين انا اعتقد هذه
خطوه فعلا يعني تؤكد على تصريح قائد الدعم
السريع بانه ويعني
[موسيقى]
مريد ان يجري مفاوضات ويعود الى طاوله ما
هي فرص نجحت المفاوض تقديرك وما الذي
سيبنى عليه ايضا للوصول الى ارضيه مشتركه
بين الطرفين طبعا
لا نستطيع ان نستبق النتائج ولكن اعتقد
المفاوضات حتكون صعبه في ظل التعنت كله من
الطرفين يعني نحن يمكننا قد نرجع الى
المربع الاول كما ذكرت وكل احد يعني يتمسك
بشروطه او بارائه
بمطالباته ولكن اعتقد هذا يعني الدور
الوسيط في هذه المفاوضات حيكون له دور صعب
في تقريب وجهات النظر بين الطرفين يعني
نحن نسمع لحد الان
اتهامات متبادله
يعني بين الطرفين
تصريحات اعلاميه لا نستطيع حد الان نجزم
90% ان نصدقها يعني كل من يقول انه احتل
90% من الخرطوم والاخر يقول هو طبعا يوسف
عزه المستشار السياسي
هل سيضطر
للدخولات
هذا
هو قوله هو مسؤول عنه كمسؤول اعلامي في
لقوات الدعم السريعه ولكن طبعا التلاعب
بالارقام بهذا الشكل يعني 90% معناه هو
مستولع الخرطوم معناه هو المفروض يستبدت
يسيطر على المنطقه ويعلن انه طرد
القوات الجيش السوداني يعني هل هل تبقى من
الخرطوم للجيش السوداني 10% من الخرطوم
اين الجيش السوداني الان لديه حاميات
كثيره في في الخرطوم يعني نحن نتوقع انه
يعني حتى الناس يعني لا تلعب بعقول
المشاهدين او المتابعين يعني الارقام تكون
معقوله وتكون فيها مصداقيه انا لا اكذبه
ولكن هو يتحمل مسؤوليه هذا التصميم طيب
الملاحظ ايضا في سياق هذه الازمه سيد
محمود ان المجتمع الدولي تعامل بشيء من
انديه في تعاطيهما بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع رغم ان الجيش السوداني هو
المؤسسه الشرعيه الوحيده في البلاد ولم
تعلن اي دوله صراحه حتى الانحيازها لقوات
الجيش السوداني ما مرض ذلك في تقديرك تريد
يعني راي بصراحه المفروض المجتمع الدولي
يدين احد الطرفين يعني احد الطرفين يعني
احنا عندنا امثله كثيره في العالم عندما
تتمرد كتيبه على الدين المفروض يعني يعني
المجتمع الدولي الحازمي صائفه بصائد الجيش
النظام وهذا شيء طبيعي يعني نحن لم نتعدى
على حقوق قوات الدعم هي فعلا قوات لها
دوره ولها وضع ولكن حتى يعني يكون هنالك
فصل في المساله كان على المجلس الامن او
حتى الاتحاد الا او على حتى بعض الدول
الصديقه ان تدين ما قام به قامت به قوات
الدعم السريع من تمرد على قائده هذا هو
قائد الجيش هناك من يرى ان وقوف المجتمع
الدولي على الحياد وعلى مسافه واحده من
الطرفين لانه يرى ان الدعم السريع هو جزء
لا يتجزا من الجيش وهذا ما كان يصرح به
قائد الجيش لسنوات مضت ولكن الجيش وله
الكلمه الاولى حتى لو كان بيصرح بهذا
القبض واذا كان اذا كان المجتمع الدولي
يريد ان يعني يقف المسافه واحده بين
الطرفين اعتقد المعادله غير مساويه يعني
وانا اعتقد انه يعني اذا كان المجتمع
الدولي يقيف بهذه الطريقه انا اعتقد بكون
موقفه سلبي ولا نستطيع ان نحقق السلام في
في السودان يعني كل يوم بنسمع ماسي والان
الحرب يعني استمرت لمده اسبوعين ونلاحظ
شكل الدمار وحجمه يعني فما بال ان استمر
مدى الحرب انا اعتقد في بلد هي بنيه تحتيه
ضعيفه يعني
بلد يعني يوعدنا الدول الفريق الفقيره على
مستوى العالم فانا اعتقد يعني يعني وقوف
المجتمع الدولي بنظر المتفرج ويرسل
الطلبات والنداءات من اجل ان يعود الطرفان
الى طاوله انا اعتقد هذا هو يعني موضوع
سلبي وحيضيع السودان
ويضيع اسم السودان ولن تكون هنالك دوله
اسمها السودان على خريطه افريقيا او على
خريطه العالم طيب هل يخشى من ان تكون
متداعيات هذا الصراع فتح جبهه دارفور من
جديد بمعنى انه اذا منتصر الجيش السوداني
مثلا قد يؤدي ذلك الى تخندق قوات الدعم
السريع في دارفور اللي معناها من امتدادات
اثنيه وقبليه معروفه في هذه المنطقه ومش
يعني فتحت انتبه الان احنا عندنا منطقتين
اللي هو استراتيجيتين ومهمتين في ولايه في
ولايه دارفور الجنينه والفاشل هنالك يعني
جبهات كثيره تتقاتل والان يعني دخلت
القوات المسلحه كجهه تنظيميه والحركات
المسلحه سوري كجهه تنظيميه واخشى اذا تعدد
عليها اي الاطراف واعتقد هي نفسها سوف
تدخل في الحرب واذا يعني امتدت الحرف الى
الى الاقاليم انا اعتقد الوضع حيكون صعب
ولكن دعني اقول لك لك يعني تصريحا اعتبره
غير مسؤول من فولكر اللي هو مندوب الامم
المتحده الخرطوم قال في احد القنوات
الفضائيه قال لو انتصر احد الفريقين ولم
ينتسل للحوار الان اعتقد سوف يجد عزله
دوليه هذا كلام خطير هذا هذا ليس فيه حياد
يا اخي يعني مثلا لو انتصر الجيش السوداني
هل السودان لا هذه انا اعتقد ليس هنالك
حياه والتصريح موثق وموجود وتناقلته
وكالات الانباء قبل
شكرا لك كنت معي في الاستوديو كاتب الصحفي
السوداني شكرا
مشاهدينا منذ بدايه الصراع كان شارع
الشيغله في حي الفتيحاء بمدينه ام درمان
السودانيه شاهدا على اشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع حيث لا تزال حتى اليوم
اصوات الاشتباكات تسمع من سلاح المهندسين
القريب من الحي
المبادرات دي المفروض يكون بالضغط
ودراسه
تكون يعني بالطريقه بتاعتك الليون
مبادرات يكون في ضغط عديل على الجيش عليه
ناس
عساكر
كلهم يتكاتفوا عشان ينجحوا المبادره ايا
كانت هذه المبادره في سبيلنا بس اوقف
الحرب وربنا يحفظ السودان لانه السودان ما
بيستاهل الحياه
قد تفجر حرب السودان في الشمال صمام
الامان الاخير لالتئام جراح جارتها في
الجنوب والتي عانت طوال فتره الانفصال من
حرب اهليه شرسه اذ يبدو ان الازمات عادت
لتوحد مصير دورتين كانت فتره وحدتهما اطول
من انفصالهما الاسباب في التقرير التالي
بظروف صعبه وتوقيت بعيد عن الامثل يتحول
الشتات في الحروب الى ازمه قابله للتصدير
سريعا الى دول الجوار صراع الجنرلين دفع
نحو 15 الف نازح من السودانيين وجنوب
السودانيين للعبور الى الضفه الجنوبيه في
اقل من اسبوعين عدد سيصل لمئه وثمانين
الفا في ثلاثه اشهر فقط اذا استمر
الاقتتال وفقا لممثله الامم المتحده في
جنوب السودان الامن شبه المنعدم كان
الدافع الرئيسيا لهروب الاله في الى وجهه
ليست اكثر امنا وفقا لما تشير اليه منظمه
الامم المتحده فرحله الفرار الممتده ل500
كيلو متر تقريبا ملغمه بالمخاطر تبدا من
العاصمه بما يتوفر من وسائل المواصلات او
السير مش في احيان والتعرض لخطر هجوم مسلح
الى حين الوصول الى ولايه النيل الابيض
اقرب نقطه حدوديه جنوبيه للخرطوم هناك حيث
يعيش نحو 300 الف جنوب سوداني في المخيمات
جلهم نزح من حرب اهليه داميه في بلد لا
يزال خمسه وسبعون بالمئه من سكانه يعتمدون
على مساعدات انسانيه تتكفل بثلاثه وعشرين
بالمئه فقط من احتياجاتهم وضع يزداد خطوره
في ظل هشاشه اتفاق السلام الموقعي عام
2018 بين فصائل الجنوب والترقب لاول
انتخابات في تاريخ البلاد تجري نهايه
العام المقبل وليس مستبعدا ان تخلق حرب
الشمال فرصه جديده لتنشيط جماعات مسلحه
يلجا اليها القاده المتمردون الغاضبون من
حكومه سيلفاكير رئيس دوله جنوب السودان
حرب ستحرم كذلك عمليه السلام في الجنوب من
الضامن الاقليمي الاكثر نفوذا المتمثل في
ضغوط البرهانه على قاده الجنوب في ملفات
امنيه واقتصاديه ولعل اسوا العواقب
الاقتصاديه تلك التي تهدد خط انابيب النفط
العابر للحدود الى بورتسودان وتحرم وجوبا
من عائدته التي يتقاسمها مع السودان لكن
القضيه الاكثر الحاحا هي تامين خروج اكثر
من 800 الف جنوب سوداني يقطن معظمهم في
الخرطوم واستغلال معاناتهم من تجار الازمه
الذين يعرضون خدمات التوصيل بمبلغ يصل الى
ثمانيه الاف دولار للحافله في ظل انقطاع
الخدمات الامميه هناك كرم حناوي العربيه
في دارفور كيف هي الاوضاح هل هناك هدوء
حذر هل هناك ملامح اشتباكات تحدثات واخرى
تفضل
نعم اهلا بكم احمد الهادي ادعنا نبدا من
شرق دارفور وفي المكان الذي اتواجد فيه
انا الان في شركه دارفور مدينه اليوم
استقبل اهل مدينه الطائعين عدد من
السيارات قادمه من الخرطوم هذه السيارات
تحمل عشرات الفاريين من القتال هناك في
الخرطوم في هذا المكان مجموعه من الشباب
قاموا بمبادره من اجل ايواء القادمين من
الخرطوم واعدوا الطعام واعدوا ايضا كافه
التسهيلات اللازمه لعوده
المواطنين الى بقيه المناطق الواقعه في
غربي مدينه الضعين تحديدا مدينه نيالا
وغربي دارفور وايضا ووسط دارفور وحتى شمال
دارفورد هذه هي ليست المبادره الوحيده في
دار في شركه دارفور وانما هنالك مبادرات
اخرى في محليه ابو كارينكا ومبادرات اخرى
ايضا في محليه عديله لنتعرف اكثر على هذا
العمل وما يقومون به نسعد بان يكون معنا
احد القائمين على المبادره نتعرف عليه في
هذه المعرفه على
الله كريم ابراهيم والكريم
الرابع كميه من الناس بالالاف يعني لا
يقدر 4000 حاجه من خلال الاربعه
والله بنقدم
يعني خلال 24 ساعه
وبنساعد بعض الناس
في معاناه شديده اليهود
ناس عمال مصانع ناس وعساكر وناس طلاب ناس
يعني مختلف الفئات فنحن هم الاسباني يا
اخي
طيبين الوضع الامني كيف في ولايه الشرق
الوضع
مستقر وضعي يامن وضعي يعني
الناس الامم الضربين الاسامي وربنا يعني
الامن والاستقرار ووحده البلاد وارجع
البلد الماضيه
تعمل الامن خلال الايام الماضيه شنو
رسالتكم بلاد السودان والله فيها تفلت
وفيها خراب والله يا اخي اولا الامن ده
دول ما بيعرف قيمته يعني اللي انفقده
الحمد لله يعني مستقرين عاملين بنقول يا
اخي بغض النظر عننا
سودانيين
وتنوعنا بثقافتنا غير المفترض ان احنا
نقبل الاخر يعني
وما يعني
يخرب بيناتنا بيناتنا
كل الامن والاستغراب يا رب شكرا جزيلا
شكرا اذا كانت هذه اضاءه على مبادره بعض
الشباب من مدينه الطائعين هم يستغلون عدد
كبير من الفارينه من القتال في ولايه
الخرطوم اذا ما تطرقنا الى الاوضاع الاخرى
في ولايه دارفور نجد هنالك هدوء في غربي
دارفور مدينه الجنينه ولكن رغم هذا الهدوء
يعني ما زالت المنظمات العامله في المجال
الانساني خاصه الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر لا تستطيع الوصول الى جميع الاحياء
التي دار فيها القتال اما في جنوب دارفور
فهنالك اخرق
للهدنه التي وقعت بين الطرفين فيما يتعلق
بعدم تجدد الاعتداءات رصدنا بالامس وانما
يعني الى علمنا بان بانه تم
الاعتداء على مبنى يتبع لجهاز الامن
والمخابرات العامه
بجنوب دارفور
اذا بهذا القدر شكرا لك من شرق دار كنت
معنا الصحفي صالح ابو علامه تحيه صالح
قالت الخارجيه السعوديه انها اجلت
4,78 شخصا من السودان من رعايه 96 دوله
وذلك منذ بدء الاشتباكات في السودان كما
اشارت الخارجيه السعوديه الى انه تم اجلاء
139 مواطنا سعوديا من السودان حيث يتم
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه تمهيدا
لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
عبر رئيس الوفد الايراني في الرياض العربي
عن امتنانه للتسهيلات التي قدمتها
السعوديه لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من
السودان مشددا على اهميه التعاون بين
البلدين
نحن شاكلون للسعوديه ولوزاره الخارجيه
ومكتبها في جده هذا تعاون جيد بين البلدين
ولدين نيه للتعاون بشكل اكبر
والله نحن ما اعرف اي اصلا مشكله وشنو
والله ما اعرفه لا مشكله
يعني اديته الحمويه للسودانيين ده تشتغل
للشراب للناس السودانيين الاخوان بس ولكن
اساسا السودانيين ذاته ما بحبه كده
وصار ضرب كثير وقصف علينا وطلعنا من
بيوتنا ورحنا على مكان امن واجت السعوديه
انقذتنا وجينا لهنا
بحمايتهم سعداء
بالمجيء عبر هذه الباخره نحن افضل الان
الاجواء كانت جيده خلال الرحله والان نحن
سعداء بعد المجيء
هذه قال القنصل اليماني في السعوديه علوي
في حديث للعربي فانه تم اجلاء 139 مواطنا
يمنيا من السودان اليوم مع منحهم تاشيره
حكوميه لمده شهر مضيفا في الوقت ذاته انه
تمت ايضا مغادره 60 مواطن يمنيا الى اليمن
طبعا اليوم هي ثاني الرحله في اطار عدد من
الرحلات الرحله الاولى كانت من يومين وتم
وصول في حدود مياه تقريبا 100 139
مواطن يمني ما بين افراد واسر وتم طبعا
استقبالهم هنا وانهاء جميع اجراءاتهم في
قسم الجوازات بشكل سلس وبشكل مريح جدا ومن
ثم تفويجهم الى الفنادق من خلال موجودين
هناك
مع منحهم
تاشيره حكوميه لمده شهر كثير من اليمنيين
لاداء عمره موجودين في الاماكن المقدسه
هنا وجزء منهم بعد ما انهوها تقريبا امس
قمنا باعاده تفويج ما يقارب 60 مواطن يمني
ومعظم من الاسر الى المناطق اليمنيه ما
بين رحلتين الى مارب والى
عدن بدعم من وزاره الخارجيه ومجلس الوزراء
مشاهدينا من واشنطن انضموا الينا الصحفيه
السودانيه فاطمه غزالي اهلا بك سيدي فاطمه
معنا في هذه النشره كما تابعنا الان عمليه
الاجلاء اجراء الرعايه الاجانب التي تمضي
على قدم الوساخ ما الذي يمكن ان نكتشفه
منها على صعيدي مستقبل هذه الازمه في
البلاد هل هي دلاله على ان الاوضاع ماضيه
نحو مزيد من العنف والتصعيد
شكرا لك شكرا قناه العربيه
رحمه لكل شهداء الوطن وعاجل الشفاء للجرحى
وعودا امنا للسودان في ظل السلام والامن
ان شاء الله قريبا نعم عمليات الاجلاء
المتواصله
تشير الى ان هنالك توقعات من قبل هذه
الدول بان هذه الازمه قد تستمر وشاهد على
ذلك ان معارك هذه
الازمه لم لم تتوقف حتى في يعني لحظات
الهدن يعني سواء كانت قصيره او كانت طويله
لثلاثه ايام او ليوم كل هذه الهدن تعرضت
للخرق وايضا تعرض يعني
مواطني هذه الدول
والدبلوماسيين ايضا لنوع من الرعب ويعني
خشيه من ان تمتد هذه
الحرب وتشمل ال واسعه من السودان ويزداد
الامر السوء وانت تعلم يعني ليس في هذه
الحرب فقط يعني ذوي القنابل وعزيز الرصاص
ولكن هنالك ازمه انسانيه اخرى اللي هي
ازمه الانسانيه المتمثله في تردد الاوضاع
الصحيه
ازمه الغذاء نفسها ازمه المياه الكهرباء
يعني هناك كل هذه
يعني العوامل رجعت هذه الدول تكون حريصه
على اجلاء رعاياها والجلاء بعض السودانيين
ايضا يعني معهم
يعني
ضيفنا الذي شرفنا قبل قليل السيد محمود
لعوته قال عبر مصادر بالنسبه
مصادر له يعني قال ان الطرفي النزاع سمى
يا ممثلين لهما ايذانا ببدء مفاوضات ربما
تبدا في القريب العاجل بين الطرفين الست
متفائله بنجاح هذه المفاوضات
انا لست بمتفائله او متشائما كهذا التفاؤل
يعني يزرعه او تعكسه الاوضاع في السودان
نعم يمكن ان تسمي كل طرف يسمي الممثلين
لهذه المفاوضات ولكن الامل ياتي حينما
تظهر جلده هذه المفاوضات ومطالب كله طرف
حينما يعني سهل ان تجلس ولكن كما يعني قال
الراحل الدكتور جونغرا يعني الشيطان في
التفاصيل
لذلك يعني ننتظر الى ان نرى ما هي
التفاصيل التي يكمن فيها الشيطان وهل
التعويذات ستطرد هذا الشيطان حتى يكون
هنالك يعني تلاقي وعمليه سلام يعني
مفاوضات تفضي الى سلام حقيقي ولكن يظل
الامل قائما ولكن الامل بلا معطيات عاده
يعني يتحول الى مجرد اماني
وكما تعلم الاماني ليس لها مكان في هذا
الواقع يعني نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن
كنت معنا الصحفيه السودانيه فاطمه غزالي
تحياتي
مشاهدينا نزاع في السودان الدائره تضرر
الاقتصادي وشح في الغذاء وعجز في القدره
الشرائيه بين الاهالي وزياده الاسعار حتى
اربعه اضعاف
حرب زادت من ثقل الوضع الاقتصادي على
الاهالي في السودان ازمه امتدت في كل
ولايات السودان واشتدت في الولايات
الشماليه
كحو المواد الغذائيه بدا واضحا في سوق
القرير في مروي
وامام شديد
ارتفاع في الاسعار وشبه عجز في القدره
الشرائيه للمواد الغذائيه ان وجدت
خضار واللحمه يعني
وصل الى 300 حتى 400 في المئه عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار للازمه
الطماطم في رمضان كانت بالف ونصف
قطاع التيار الكهربائي زاد الطين بالله ما
اضرب بمخزون الغذاء بعد الاحداث
قالت
ان شاء الله
ومع استمرار المعارك يتوقع تضرر مخزون
الغذائي في عبوم السودان لنحو كارثي
على وقع ثمار الاشتباكات وغياب اي بوادر
لحل قريب وصف برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في
السودان الوضع الانساني في البلاد
بالكارثي
شبحوا المجاعه يلوح بالافق في السودان مع
استمرار الاشتباكات وغياب اي بوادر لحل
قريب
المسؤوله الاتصال في برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه لنيكنزلي وصفت الوضع الانسانيه
في السودان بالكارثي
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي يشدد على ضروره
وقف القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال مساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
قلق وخوف وخيمان ايضا من ارتفاع جنوني في
اسعار المواد الغذائيه والوقود
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي اكد ان المستودعات
التابعه له نهبت واخرى تعرضت للقصر
انما دمرت طائره تابعه لخدمات النقل
الجويه التابعه للامم المتحده في مطار
الخرطوم الدولي
ارقام فلكيه قد تستمر في الازدياد في ظل
الحرب الجايه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات